>> YEAH, ONE FOR LOU
>> YEAH, A WITH THAT TRIANAHEIME
FINDS CROSS, HOLDING ON, GIVIN
THEM S S OFFENSIVE ZON
AND HE WAS I
FRONT TO REDIRECT THE OUTE
SHOT
D MAYBE IT
WENT PAST THEM AS HE DOESN'T GET
A GLT ONE WOULD GO
BACK TO PROVOROV
10 SECONDS O G BACK DOWN LOW FON
AS YOU WOULD GO ON AND THEY MUST
HAVE GOTTEN A PIECE OF IT AN
NOAND BY JONES
>> THEY HIT THE POST AND GREAT
JOB ON STEALIN THE FLOOR CHECK
THEY WILL STEAL THAT PUCK TO
TRACK IT DOWN TO PUT IT ON
GOAL
COULD NOT CONTROL IT
SONNY MILANO ON THE DRYSDALE WI
VAR OPPOSITES FROM PERIO
NUMBER ONE
ALDGSON WAS CHECKED.
NOW THE SHOT FROM THE ANGLE AN
THE SAVE BY JONES MADE OFF T TS.
THAT ONE WILL HIT THE POSTAND TN
THE POWER PLAY WIT WOBBLE IN
THE PUO PROVOROV TO SE
THEM ACROSS THE PLAY AND THE
THE FLYERS HAVE TIED UP THE GAME
AT THREE
HIS ONE UP
UNDER HIS LEG.
ANAHEIM HAVING A AS HE
COULD DO EVERYTHING.
LINDBLOM TO THE LINE AND THE
SAVEO CROSS TH
LINE
THE DROP PASS AND BENOIT WAS
CAUGHT U SCORE, THE HIGHLIGHT  N
THE THIRD PERIOD
BUT SUDDENLY THE
WILL FIND THEMSELVEST INTO THAT,
THE TIME OUT, TH